You're really at a level where you can compete with Lint, so
mix me up too I'll throw
more shock opponents into the field
Shoot A
super long pass that comes up while throwing this up
No, it's not a linear pass
Puya's aim is
terrifyingly beautiful  It's beautiful in a battle The
speed of resources can
catch up Radiation bastard I'll crush it ordinarily I'm there too  If
you don't realize that
path, feel it as a line,
not just as a line.
Nambu is terrible The
top 3, who could only fight individually,
began to work together as a team I
thought we could win if we stopped the dog But
which opponent will accelerate the evolution of the game?
and
guide